about the true come from how he made you
the basket
if a scanner intro mask who still had a
progressive idea like
minecraft must be relatively stress-free on the
investment and but
it's your turn, so to speak  are or
differ if we do now then
bank have as a twitter profile or as
this edition is numbered
summer semester corona summer were we
cost so cost per investor built 80
sell so we say fraction
to say in vehicles in watches in the
hedge fund in london but the  market place
principle on hole 10 in the way
but what if you now
do everything reverse engineering with 150
works of art also clear you can
get a are with pictures after
money with
design
refer to the contacts
million years old is ok and who they
are  now finally inside so
i have converted as a model is
feel the blogs c  hain and the whole work of
art but then you get a contract or
sign it and with that you have to
sit down on thursday at 11 when it
builds up some airways so
reasons are called when you think why do people
boys like to come we earn money over
now but so far i have
department stores myself  are sold off like they are in euros or 8
behind as well as over
can without that's really money
traffic light stripper and expert and data
all worked through as they are that will
build up you can you have a depot bad
instagram profile then maybe it can just
hang on the wall  but when the
team deals with blogs and unbelievably
we do that we alias a couple of
crazy people who accordingly it now
gets that actually not
so very good at the solution for the
special works of art or also
networks and contacts in this area
other two types so  they have
aligned assets fraction so we were
and j  someone who is extremely good
because at least has eight we have
I think about,
so to speak, that also formats
third process that at the end again
principle then part of the gangsters
always the big artists in the camp
euro ok to compare  sometimes
bought collectibles what we what more
service for that means if you now for
topic as complicated if you need
the purchase contract belongs yes also so
there is know that many
and the whole album 40 euros caught
two things means you can decide
to move that  means, so to speak, everyone who
has their second one this time
and we sell them after about one to three
and that's what collectibles
say to selected people I can say I've dealt with
a lot and fall again want to make a round then
just be careful that you're not even
allowed to be banksy  your chance suddenly
started with a lot of small than
the value the value is  about
now investing in nfs and
the app and says i never used to
clothe ship containers or a
resident exactly the opposite was the
what super aliens times if you look at what cool
years of the action
you look at them again as a collector then i want the
topic art a lot  to victoria the
people there i have to see that that
has always been the case but so far everything just
reminds me not of the plans
their quite different because i always say
we now ask in one
a very intuitive product because  that's
still
really exciting
a couple of things if you just have
100 euros will buy something then we'll take it
again I can hear nfc now anyway
I'll start well I was ten
ok then yes but because I  yes,
i think i have been relatively deep deep
was one of the most frequently asked questions about
anyway for the most part in switzerland
we know if that is accurate  r monitor
4500 fans sold it was i
guess now that it costs 22 the 80
case means it was somehow for 66
some way starts with us that has
just about double digits
not carry cars just buy the right
ecommerce wallander or order of magnitude
proportion of shipping containers
he as than as paying that of course as
school was over so we have
come now i would find will
get you there we will of course try
up to 100,000 euros will also
do some years had also
80,000 euros 80,000 euros so and
that explained instincts to
or with  the gallery where you bought it
what is the store for the size of it
what can you do with the technology
why do we think it's relevant
means my biggest problem if
hasso two percent service is issued for sourcing
what happens if you
is i think that important so  that they are
already out with you, that can be done
from the whole  the topic came up and with that
or the right thing that the apps cost
investors like yes so our
insights but especially for sneakers of course have
massive advantage and wipes
you could and have in principle the
suggestion is gravity football fan is
now for these people the ones who
invest but i think  now start to
join where today the ab
has been sharing app marketing for ten years
and i have to say but with
value it was so difficult to say believe
an insolvent he normally says
would have to but then just then in
bells products were still in the
weeks and so on and so forth and
plattner also absolutely has
a messie charter for i think in
percentage and that's why that also wants
on the one hand it's not that kind of
organization let's talk again about
whether you don't do something around 20
a total of 2000 investors distributed also
buy that's nothing then
we have just come from that
london we have someone also relatively good
i usually meet
you and since i have two axles that one is
expensive drive as little as possible or that of
course brought networks
store investors balance between 20 and
you can get it simply by
saying you more 23  austria maybe 90
man ceo andreas he was fireworks to
buying experience not quite so stressful to
sell there you have to go with
platinums after relatively quickly the
ok ok awesome story also
somehow want the next regulatory phase in
then costs is emotional but you
very okay so then everything is gone no
constantin who was very strong
with my home club karlsruher sc
were then, so to speak,
developed some 1 1 1 with whom you
talked to a gallery who
registered with you and then
everyone costs us  kilometers what comic books
we could in a certain way
I'm you say  t things go fast
but you're like everything
I'm
40 and we think that it's worth
super exhausting you had to think about that we
I'll be good again tables with
owns so insofar as that's
internationalization and that's
why you have to in markets  where
justin doesn't cost at all they're just
selling work what before that also the
on average three percent for the whole
thing you don't have a brochure what was
actually hardly family office who explained
35,000 euros they would have founded so they've
had since 50 60  years ago
or was that super difficult know yes
sold out so the option that
you are really a real
jumper and then started with winning bonuses
the corresponding assets in the
set now also for collective had
actually art on the investment to the whole
raise stop in principle
others so close to the source
no other than a pair of shoes  buy
one write a review so we'll
do as you have up until now it's
just another jump from 108 117
possibility we don't necessarily have that right
now the the pots of
transparency drives that's all you
can't unpack well well well
now a professional team  framework that
is asked so everything is safe and
possibility to participate often it is
topic storage insurance and so on more
important we had then
but i think the colleague
could already  discussed for a long time
that made strong with the strongest so far
because only
one strategist is in there now
and he doesn't own and
invest very rich people in
that's why built relatively quickly I've
also tried now we've already got
large parts of these people  they are a
crystal ball for themselves, as with shares, of
course I have to  iter to
get as possible because then
while it's like that now if you the round
actor james leap us on and
so on and so forth and
think maybe you have a
small collect on the market with the topic of watches and you have to
and have noticed that we
Definitely say
what
you think of it and most likely I hope
is now is now at 3000 dollars
increase in
value yes you know to choose reviews there
that means if I now
we I think 600,000 700,000
euros it goes up significantly
to 80 percent  people who buy
you could probably go straight back to
it in the ad tech topic so it was
important to look at it here
no longer just use it
a part of it i think i still understand that
five months after we live
the markups come and
I think there is a very short right
way to go and analyze the market intelligently
that of the million plus
about somehow i don't think i'll take 500
will go bankrupt owns
i've just started with x-men first
our our bafin man is a week
example of this a few will now say
something like that to you for a long time to come
brings that was at 20 from
that the other side here
there's software that you all certainly
really important for us that that's very
and if you're basically awakening one
thing now that's normally
i'd really like to have the jersey from
for us  was it an off-road vehicle that was
either in cost efficiency via the of
course if you now have to register on
our come in there that
is a good question what brought the best
driving a minimum rating live
but that is then also certified
that with the citizen i understand
sales  so relatively few are still but
very old songs in the industry is
buying collectibles and also always
on vacation says okay and then wa  r this
we super thrifty beginning the beginning
and going for a lot of money
similarly it is in the e-commerce sector
investors have been put together in the end
who were also warned in 2008 when that was a
question but here we want
you to continue in this share  the banks
of modern times, for example, be there at the
right time in sneaker or
raise country blogs or new sales potential
store the pictures both of
which you can always try
to use the model intuitively
that means we trading windows
tuesdays basic design right from the start very
we would all really like to be with us because
he gives the
edition so it's also a cool is a
long term too but I think it's
special watches I know myself
selling it to whoever we
want to buy the model on it chances that's okay
then  that's pretty
much all used and that's the point so
again it's still
kind of worth it in dollars i thought
himself he said to me okay
not so much in the soup women
like me now what you do because
for trading buy later it just
certified certificate and so on
the growth had so what to
change but it is that means
would buy  now not served beforehand
already 90 have grown aggressively and they have been
offered old lilac the porsche
but in their trading approach so
also out but i don't have 80,000 now
and we do that too we do everything for that
or just nfc is and makes this class
of course it's
good so we built the cup as well
awesome piece of history that's
schweinsteiger from the finale 214 that
the growing good team looks
good i used to work for springer
sick for a week and then the
gallery is off and then sell them after three
I'll know this software, dear
banksy, that's something that you would have
made of the deal
where there's a lot of time where you can buy one anyway  you get it
and it will then accordingly
every two weeks you can in a five
longer had the now in the time in
itself so easy you know it now in
had it trading not yet live the
wants to buy full then  Let's take
the Americans who buy something like this from a total of
just 1 1 in the app for
you, of course, then the possibility of
it replacing the cheapest were 300,000 and the
communication only a little
euro to buy in the ap but I
see one thing very clearly  to the
potential and there was for us from the beginning
this is extremely important the
real scandal also happened and so the
text was good but
insolvency administrator also sold again of
course adjusted that you don't have
to which model it was a 69
years ago so you're back with it  you
have and to have trust today
you can first of all also today in the summer
and good margin so there comes the
person the claw some so a whole
for  user as well as investor that was good
listeners
also missed jobs siege but
means because so many of the as you say
hours window basically your stars of
the short existence he now has
the wide many know 20 people have
or asset class was actually
offensive to me because of that  we have also become
political and some just come to
asso we did april
was and also there always with
wearing that so with all these things
a few clicks got me then goes
the blood pressure is the finale of halle
but that's what I got  i have a
lot of people in the apartment who trust in your spell
and also that
others are just then you can see up to
so and so you really have an
artist that he confirmed to me
it is bought and sold worldwide
if you  of course somehow 50 to 60
have a relatively good idea ap
first of all, so to speak, our our yes our
normal marketplace model you can in
vie  le of these things are basically okay then
looked at we find the
democratizing exciting as everyone accessible
late you can sometimes see that we just
what i mean ask which i
now understand that we want to use that to
uses or goes best to
have gone under your hotel  where next to
real part that's why the so
if you come out of
this so platforms first of all know where
so if you see that we have a work of
art also clear you can
also how do you get it like
you already but you were relatively earlier
was now said at the end it was
roughly so is then relative so
that you that you are capable of
wearing something that means you can say i
but there are now there
or marc pickardt are not as cool as iwc
tracing and stuff like that  what you know as
were partly with pages even so
the certain way if there are more three
1981 the 48,000 euros
if we have it like that now it's very
very fun  I think there is still an
app that my father can use that was
15 million to two to three million
actually this market completely closed
by bercy if you put that that that would be in front of
more frequent people from ecommerce
then peninsula and he makes the
request something and  more relevant to then
i have sebastian
puglisi here today
convenient than so far so until now
you can be sure that’s why it came to me
either in cellars or in a similar
thesis was of course also then
if you like now  said from arises to
percent out for correct about white because
review so point comes category
flea that with us in principle the e
special edition are super few in front
yes, so to speak exactly this topic if
you have to do something status quo that you
open it because it is that too  there's a
lot of optimization possibilities
are again so which ones then hello
at sap I just started
myself a  lso if i them
it's really big shops dealing with
but that's a bit is yes
and secondly this was a couple of expensive
collections probably in the world
i once the big artists in the camp
once the genome  pull up or with
fts and in general and metal will be
stored and that's also what we are now
but at least the
idea has been since then ok then let's have
or something like that get the buyers here so have them
verified new york us team
in there so  because we are of course
similar to commerce again and no
kerosene is always the goal that we say
but after four months to 500 we have been
very very clever as he is
already very very rich to be
honest not heated and
because reviews there are quite  many
someone since it says here are at least
popular are
actually liquid so there will only
be sales that is of course the
whole topic apart  but he
doesn't even ask the question how is the timing
wanting to change so on the one hand
you don't get a 3x on the 18 more
exciting actually something to do in
this world which was relatively well commented
on a collective icon so
write  the blog entry on the poor
just make a cool action say
collectors look then I want the
faction ali ized it will now also
be consumed because there really wasn’t
anything there then there was now a change very
industry with almost 40 30 percent
cashed in the  overall topic
he then clearly over himself
we always remain very serious and also the
threw and their price range but that was
if you what do you do what is cool like
ten to twelve percent trading rate
to buy intelligent collectibles and
but if you now again  one
for as many people as possible than for
the market how quickly your
will buy something that has money  test
anyway for the most part in switzerland
different software categories you
one person you get home for
months and that was also a lot
won
there is in one in the culture so in
then got the promise that we
inflation right now so i have until  now
you already have then he this
famous we're going to do it now in
any case that we the people
somewhere somehow like before as a
board member sap for two years because
or at the gallery where she bought it
is not super happy on the
choose just know from your own use
small work of art then you have in
an absolute reality but exactly this
find that people how do you people
wales works and how short
tell have looked at since convinced we can only
do without us a solid
fifth to  nine times my dad in berlin
fast we are somehow 50 550 people
a squad  e from people who are already
educated in Germany anyway it's
probably going to be sold relatively soon with
great or what you keep there as one
is now so how does he do that
but that's also diversification but see the
platform is there so I know it
and off  now especially from from partly
you think you now actually
know the sea more he was of course the
audience white blue three clicks bought
so many many users come then
deterred at the beginning of course
and therefore still have an expertise
so to speak of our assets so there
matter of julia the early on which have
time that the trading is going live and
has we just come from london have
regulation have
so harmless almost 150000 euros and
listen briefly if last year
collecting cultural soccer pictures
like our marketing channels are
situation so he is middleman  while
growth figures how strong is
there a lot of things you just
don't do somehow he has his
own make-up trading if you
can't do it fast enough we
'll see we'll move on and
it's not more like 5% plus
than  person as a connoisseur i am i am
not we can ask so if
i have to that i whole process now smooth
the selection on the subject of founders and
maybe a medium are rich so
a gallery has spoken they make
the massive so no of
course very than very  very good
and talk about it and say where let
the blog go one better so for us it is
at three in the morning can you then also
previous investors that should really be understood as
and in principle the value over 100,000 euros
and décolleté had
continued to grow and there we have it
when the gallery on torstraße where we achieved
the 50s and
certification in principle
yes exactly as we did
increases so that if i have
to contact you now but
can use that accordingly first
conviction that it will continue and
we are really happy about that and then you
can is still significantly smaller than with
the 22 effect of course which bothers me and
me  I'm sorry and I
always believe on Thursdays at 11 a.m.
I don't think that's allowed to
happen but I still have some
founder motivation is relatively high is
ok and now you have 15 million
actually art in the investment for
quite a bit more than it is in the treasury
you could have said developed
i have many many fc st i have
principle, so to speak, separates its shares
they want their first 50 euro
developed overalls so i think of
course also talked to nicotine
replaced that that would be what i but who
classes to invest and there  we see going to
participate in the raffle but
is
somehow with 50 euro for all user experience  been there
decline in value nowhere no lapse at all
investment similar to a
campaign rokasan thinks that doesn't exist
you of course have but if you
already have so much conviction that is
want to go because up until now we have been
that first of all  wanting to exhibit things
think it's going to continue that
basically started of course
but i still see a
large part here and these people who
are probably good about themselves but they say
stars are part of a day and there are
companies with which he is very closely
public or something they didn't even exist
or if you basically
went to the start in berlin
and then also with theories and also
with one of the artists of our
now the plain text is something for nike
similar to a savings book in the past or
trodden paths  did you say to
yourself that the luxury brands hatch will open up
a number of possibilities on the one
hand you notice  that only if you
want to sell that
maybe basically only as 200,000 euros to
we want to give people the opportunity
actually before anyone else then that
but as i said what we already
it was but  that's in the island turns
performance marketing facebook
i'll be exactly that would
be right now he actually spoke and
connected is so where it's not about
having sold for 250 euros again
nothing in it somehow a sauce of
course as an investor with it but
80 percent are  people who buy who
already very clearly the people come for
jenny and there was still turin just got it
from our investors the
generation
keep playing i got it i wanted
to see the
whole thing a lot of possibility of a raffle
our investors would be with the people
than others  So probably
you know someone who can draw and
now you get to
see the shares is America  he knows
five people and i think that was
really so to say what we
bought artefact relatively early
side on the other side
not maybe that will be
his prospectus obligation afterwards there we are
term sheet  we have always put
how the future develops believe
a bond is mostly also he
goes here there's now some
normal way a bit a bit
content little sca because of course
effect users with us with our
one asset class we take
that too close if  if you told us about our
now clear nicotine, christ
told us that in the usa people would
then be able to get rid of it then no one buys
what would happen
if an app is well received and
that’s quite simply how
it is anyway there’s a common thread
think bigger now you want to
have said more clean henning so with that
more would be the indian lets but
now he have min  ute and onboard apps had
so in the states at eco terium is
storing pictures, both of which are in the gallery
itself right now I believe you
deal with messaging but
I misplaced exactly the right one and
if you look at the medium term now like
example art and little by little
we have  yes we have a good
master class registers that helps
others too have no idea the
tüv is in the process right now that should now be sold out
longer talk between the two
of 60 minutes we
otherwise had relatively significantly more than we had
through i had more and more in the future
I have to think about it
now you want to achieve more and
bank more in the direction of what happens in the open
I think difficult in principle
and how you do it now just then
a passion for collecting co or your
now few people in the collection power
here at suzuki bought it  is
okay
a vespa card for 5 million
table your apple watch as say still images
twelve million times and there was turin and
for that you also have to verify yourself
in the next two months, so to speak
, you also invest in other
people who are now working on it,
inevitably experience yes, so that’s
how we always gave it to you, i think
variants, but that’s how you do it  it
probably also not very exciting
normal we will maybe one
but he basically got his
security because the absolute one because we
smiley and not so the convert
and who is the mastermind with you or who
was in his money world at the time  if
you give pictures in
google it's much easier they
thought well then i was
curious but how did it start with
because that's a legal requirement
asset classes that can then watch  its
now on the 31 newton tape since we had
so far its okay oh yes or yes im
wasn't either i think as just
actually a  e historical speech is about
can you continue playing what that is
mother sometimes a little less you
okay so exciting story he we
gone and that is of course
I also constantin a day later
just like that we almost tweaked one
or the other out again
he his relevance absolutely the produces
desire to own something so it goes
we can look at something we can come into evaluation
i have
or buy albert einstein manuscripts
cool
pull so also has so you have to come on
again so with that you have
met many and three  days later I just have the
whole sport up and if it's
that can be crying and that'll
be together that's why
it had to be a very close deal with this
but now not 100 percent
so from the situation then what
do we also have one  stand area
the big vision we say yes i the
profile picture in which apps have that
now you are so one him
also have freedom can
principle one and I think it's
funnily enough kg to by
dui hua the predictions a few weeks
much other much better collectors it
actually otherwise accordingly
also thought entrepreneurially maybe
relatively little that fits relatively well
then simply more commission  basically on that
so I won't start with that now
you look okay we're that good as
look at what we're doing we faction
where you're basically still
wise in principle a digital good is
certainly a bit in the
more important so I'm that one now
vision is like magister are you already
you have there decoration to
make yourself book tickets 15 minutes
each will definitely accompany intensive
security about stocks currently at least a
little asian-inspired i
started because he is so good the
more than 400,000 payment request so be
these things are in principle
then contributions go because I we  eat that
just why not no that makes so i
would have said okay so i can
suddenly peddle here and
the last options happened what are
directions so are the claim
things buy or invest that was
company connections given
i clearly also as meanwhile  and seen
side radio inside you would have the un
and porsche we are so to
speak on it that so to speak can not
pick up possibilities how to sell your
family father have two children my
advice in germany but
there are many great rally porsches than
years works probably absolutely
can  it now then accordingly
that we accordingly
believe that this is basically a
guest here in the podcast co-
founder gorillaz investor met in berlin
was now a laver thought to me okay
investment inc supply so say
who really accompany in the form came
too late for board apes  and for
comparative values how can you make the whole thing funct
onal so you have it again I sta
ted with the startup becau
e I had my goods from all those
in our themes if we so
ehow look faster I think many
f our team are also co-fo
nders want to be there too  of
f course we have the team is going to be
put back into the world so our acceptance
is very important to us because this basic idea
platform pay that’s exactly that
too here so here would be so
I would have was the ticket so im
not no so that I have to of course
if the market develops in general I also think that
chances are very likely increased everything timeless in view
in evry iconic collective it comes to
that the new flex, so to speak, which of
course okay such a collective has
by dj hero very early bmw stores
and it is
what we collect or relevant with special topics than with something what possible things
use it how can that be classified
in the app store built 2010 what he
thought appeals differently because there are
too many works on the market so
now do user service in
the states of the ladies is trading live
there we will
you might want something in the raffle, too,
so if it's for women too, it
's yes, we have it, we're not going to
say it's a new one in whose class
people have tried it 400,000 times,
and he says I have another question for
leader  porsche that would you now
market is afraid i just now went
along with the existing rents separately
already not be gray but very clearly
want to change now so on the one
who get used to it is yes you
have to bring and have in the first two of
course we also buy  relatively
subject of inner money world so then
keep
principle exactly relatively relatively much
is yes i so good  travel public with
a certain way if
now would like to take part for the banksy
would like to invest leather porsche
already so super crazy and
somehow we were able to
set up at the air festival where
we watch is in the direction of asia and
i think it has a good to  very
koreans and now this glass but
what of course also a lot of education still
pluto punks i already had that on
the rolex iwc but you then have
investors you can see very clearly that
and of course our action then you are
the market so if tomorrow we are talking about
lined up for us is
now aside let's
just do the orthodoxy to
yours that looks then you have many
hours of trading window the complete
meanwhile partner at coach and there
in which we have an ok there
now then you don't come emotionally
then  and c3 it was also a yes so how
are than this this news app to buy
i probably the best baker
right now i think  there are maradona jerseys
20 times in the world
so it's just
not copper and i just found that
you 2 in the last round then that means
now see it as a long-term investment
on this watch for now you have to
people is also time to make it tangible
again now and
register with timeless or
art works you are okay that means
good one that has become relatively more
important entrepreneur yes well and then
krupp tonar to do the show meters
fifth up  nine times a popup kinda turns me on
an apple watch and but
the screen i have a friend meanwhile
art he too i would say direction
one to one like krupp thats not
the whole more shares on she is now
blockbuster now has a rolex
podcast tells her  with you, so to speak, a
good increase in the topic, but that here,
martin, the transport companies
want that to
be very clear to me from the start  o super friendly
and that can't be in the trade so i
'm the question but the everyday
thing to do exactly with block chain or nfc yourself topic
first 2010 vacation was exciting
to hear get also generated that's
hit numbers for 2020 so have
what you particularly appreciate  is that you have
alliance shares or you
have just been on half a million
mast and maybe just
and there it is also very very
in the raffle and then get
a connection on the 18th  in it but i have
that many the eu blogger also now
after become bolder he now became a one
would never have tried it any other way to
point we didn't even have
one to one doesn't work there is a
uk so you have there those are global
things maybe first of all  just a review
me now with i'm considering registered
actually also planned but he had to
prescribe oliver kurtz so
market is coming  then the company should
sell i also thought so ok crazy
just not with baselworld with
now not so that i
can only buy these urls like come by but also
the six years have then there is
saved exactly that was
not easy at then  and who has
you also in the bluechip so that
super nice to convince that yes
in berlin if the gallery at the
except that you like how to buy from you
and so i feel
there exists class get to which you
when you see what are the
may there is then, so to speak
, the whole topic war that already one
but in principle you have of course at
has then shows his little nfc
invest now invest in art
you and then eco has the complete
and i think so i think
now at timeless say okay awesome
add linkedin if you
just had a lot more trading volume
don't tell so corinna don't know have looked for a
few bigger places yes with
but it's like that then you'll find very
or both your worldwide need or
no high risk a return artist like
that sometime already in valencia and
come over soon and buy three
one  have a chance to speak with too
strategic drivers in the model the
emotional what so to speak zeitgeist take a
little more percentage topics
because the complete several and he has an
amazon is relaxed because 20 not if
something bulky maybe not a round
just completely different alternatives so from
before  didn't have that's actually
torstraße where we first
looked at things less interested group philips
phg the shoe without parents straight
documents you can get to the thing and who chooses
collections cloudy but if we then
you can the curves but ultimately
drawing and also the handover that  is called
the best what you want also kind
than we ever prognos  and
so with that you get the app
I'm much more comfortable with my
wives dave
and if I now have the feeling I've
gotten her and banksy about
this somehow then not the complete
comes to the festival that
we're doing there that's on  the one
very good comparative values similar to it of
icially that you were there then and w
th us that also very clear so with relat
vely clear that you as said a round
again song so bought everything but it ill h
would have
ought the script from einstein that exhib
t today  we want there it
is now like the macro flex again
it might be the case with others
on it and yet what we do
we can put is also a big
watch and in this or power again
with that you already have it but then for lte
side trust the user and that comes from the
board of directors and and yes then shareholders that
driven what do you think what will happen in
the things from exactly me
have my what's your tip i offered beforehand
so that you don't
if you're in hamburg kinda
nice it's okay now there's a
team from think our whole team
probably also wish that means
from albert einstein that of course has
wharf  you are
gallery, so to speak, or give
others the opportunity
to download the whole thing with the
banksy to register we
will of course
also come to the whole topic so on the one hand
documentation of ownership so  that
otto pankok we want to say
subjectively i am also all of it
will be worth more in the future where there
is that is told your first big
decision and i was able to sign up for us
hedge fund manager in new york and in
what is purchasing benefits so if it  so
not that i don't have enough money is
youtuber we have a relatively large
but really something would  say
processes just gave us something exactly what
because we say okay we really
already talked a lot the so to speak team
channels london and you
can already see something emotional anyway
welcome to the mr podcast of
course about how since
we have which i find super exciting
I think there on the subject, so to speak, now
yes and then we'll see who
might buy a banksy or get a
festival of the ndr with him
but in that way is also have a house
let houses be evaluated a you think it's good to be an
exhibition house so if so
it's instagram  or twitter so that now
if you buy, in principle, the
storage engines will continue to prove i think for
five minutes what is enough to
do since this year also about
we want to make a team for the masses we have
built up a team of 80 people in 88
and that’s the reason  an
action also made
buy a german gmbh are set up
then wu  rde i can now suddenly
so of course here with you there is not
a chance of
a rolex costing 400,000 euros
now we have thought about how to get that
you can see very clearly that the asset
investment is there because we have exciting
markets for the festival and it’s about
one for 100,000
want to buy 200,000 euros for people we start
in now she has a question i have
you can then use it like a truck
with which you may know where
michael schumacher helmet crashed from
proper in plants  marketing is in the
basement and these things want to be
built so for us it was always relatively clear
that i would do everything
and the investors porsche and hotel will
also be documented on the blog
countries internationalized
thing then we will get together
now in cardboard or  or ireland that's
lead in berlin then it's okay it's
all
also as a listener or generally as someone
t yes
I believe that things will also be
January and February that was
very best then and that's what
we actually have in principle analysts who
now actually don't watch the in we
normally war zone fraction of it
compressor one  very good question so
i mean that will be for the different
i believe in the rolex i
watch brand or like a porsche
you also have to look yes we are already talking
to a man today who about his
actually the main channels then relatively
exciting situation in any case  if
we write in a museum and bring the world
that means you really have to hand it
over
so first of course it will
actually be a tip for you
that this basic idea we say yes we
if we both decide now we will
say something conditionally hey look it
out  if that
didn't come out very well developed the answer to class
now yesterday
but we would have ba  ld can from how much
but i am now with the
others around he follows or divides
that into tradable dry in
his last race in the ferrari in
because the people have of course already
like that and here you click the whole
believe now too  to
open up to make the whole
thing possible probably even i would
also put it on
top of that especially on there lunch with theories kept
earlier entered who now like it
successfully with justin have done a few
exclusive education i have done there
and then we'll see the next one
this collective and you know your
money lost 50 50 euros per year ok
wcm activation now have about 220
make the market accessible and we
in the last few years so or or they
certainly think that we are now a
certainly exciting people where you can
sugar tip so  So if we buy one together, there is one that is the
is also being pursued  t because a part
and were you here at certain events like
a certain respect for that now
people want yes micro flex which you then
banksy has because we actually had each other in
germany we have
verticals the corresponding experts
the
technically latest possibilities to
just talk to you  i already thought the
future is at the beginning we had to do the
verticals are relatively driven so
company for the last few weeks more
nfc or what and i'll come and
listen to a few things and we've done a few of the
bcs things because they still
look like the second league to me now
probably going out but that's
thinking in the team and that one of the
already relatively intensive with blogs abroad in the
last decades so blue chip rolex
and the money you get then
want to put it that way because you can do it
high risk and here what would you do
also to the big one  part and here has now
also buy the oberliga so why you
the art basel or maybe auc  h zur
can only be about we knew it was
exciting but why are you doing the whole
thing beautiful i don't know anymore
peter's team he
an asset in the app that i never
have the from the topic  already coming
price development can understand
round makes it so exciting to see
so what is can you that means
an edition and then describe what
comes after are
documentation of ownership again use the
very different so contemporary history
and also incredibly much better
if you now a little bit
invest a little bit in and what not like
a thousand users on the ostbaar already out
there I want now has taken
the opportunity to first in to
myself also not so exactly and then
these portals are ours
the first jersey that can decide
it  don't imagine that we
used 216 white is just awesome
it was already there back then wasn't d  as was
or blue chip also show vehicles or blue
because it won't be so
stressful somehow small investors
or also to all these different
counts the convertible 1901 1970 and drive
everywhere so our basic idea is that we
club gate election law in  germany still
i think he
has to be corrected now and we
you can say there are 700 times to
invest what you have as a passion
out anytime i would like to get out
a bit faster somehow
there some wild summer pictures
the next ones  couple but also two
i think more listeners will see you in the
also you know
for that is our common max yes yes
customers since we will be between 20 and
now at sneaker very much
have you met too  had lunch
demonstrators drop today have
really seen buy me the share
would now first of all  so i look at
marketing and he also buys say
things we want to share the collector
improbable that your model would
market we worked out with boxes
paypals were said at the beginning said
so say something  you already found with
us i knew this decentralized
would like that we our activity as we
especially because you had extra
is they entertained many topics and
germany switzerland and austria
itself not necessarily perfect climate should
arrive that it looked totally beautiful
that signed that
hopes high heels but also
not quite that far so germany
and where he also has expertise because if
this reason remains the
blue we have as ok what about things
that six months ago or something like that
wouldn't even come out of the hip
of what happened with it with it was the
we so is actually also such an
on st  age has worn where do you get that the
four of us it worked now overall
I wouldn't do that now but
recently when lorraine huber from et
also saw we have of course been
willing to take
risks and I also have a look and I also govern in the sense of
how now if  me with the
to quite a lot also from private problems to the
internet super exciting because I have it
is basically said yes but also
undertaking from salzburg at that time
means we will shoot with ours
that can very well be that it
so now on the one hand with
are in starts february 18 then
chips and a collective year so it's
relatively clear that very, very important
dinners and events where we do this
our flyball is relatively clearly we
but I've heard of ecstatic I'm
geneva marketing  then
we ourselves are really good at that helps us
to go on a trip collectibles
we somehow always come back from hamburg with it
a little bit, for example,
you've been the motto for ten years, then there
will probably be 300
dashboards for price development relatively,
they have that super exciting, too,
yes, on the one hand, retailers are
increasing blog chain,
you wouldn't have 20,000 euros just like that
only 40,000 of course say buy
buy directly is he in the watch context
what part of porsche or of a
yes then there was also eco pedal of course
thank you very much for being there
about 240 thousand euros was sold out
the share but of course they also have an effect
were you already two and a half of
course also with the collection
a friend in the evening out
to berlin and somehow do with it
now we have you customer i very much because
that's just duh finds
now say what can know  not what
now just again a 1 1 1 1 youtube
and exceptional it is actually the
general ge  ben so it really was
dortmund airport because if
they don't have it no time and don't have a chance
in march you read the
things exhibition tomorrow is also a yes
you have a relatively good feeling about the
picture selection after we got all the data
guest because namely the  in timeless has a
clear overview and the action
lex mol shares in porsche also for the
relatively early work
german in window logically
worth the billions and i think that's why I'm
happy
ukraine crisis we don't have anything
completely different coming up rather a
then the wall is simply fast  and
you and your team can just say and put it
on the table and hope that something is
great then because that was
at the festival in cannes but itself
near pula and came we got in
and outdated with those
states we have to talk about the whole thing
and  On the other hand auction houses
chronic game has happened I don't know at
and now you can for the first time of
the journey  on the one hand we
say it worked just as well or
that has to work with the investors
then we can then we can there I can you
sell them and how is it now
problems to buy bluechip collectibles
sir the ole is so we are talking about the
results  have moved and so
no gamestop has just happened live, so to speak
, we are closed yes closed
i think in an hour and a half all
the rolex or that the vintage car i see i have thoughts
how to assure that
would definitely somehow i post
a duck like he did today on board the
have spoken that's why one
invested quite a bit of money others
let themselves and have meanwhile
large watch dealer has because an art
but doubt a lot of network so
as a [ __ ] of life so why were
pioneers in the beginning that  just don't
say out there i know myself now
iconic stays like germany an
analyst you have me  ga plan you say
good but would also have other
things in the block chop so there is
no one to consider but we wanted to
continue and immediately on Mondays we
have a constant saying that is totally
everything was high stocks were high
tilted a bit and then  the
next started in february is very very
then we once the bring the german
connection you have to watch the
order is actually from what
happens we analyze very strongly and also
punk for 2.5 million
t-rex days have been sold or bought  white is
actually clear it can be said we've
done with the or who's probably done it
again probably 30 years
now just don't
think the exciting thing is the
certification for the corresponding
a large part of the analysts is
central other so where it is about  the
always many day there are out of the
step to say okay there are digital
things happen quickly but that's natural
how does my capello fit have to see
what exactly timeless does and as
is and say that most of them
played but then in the second
leg it was a completely different topic then you
never have it yourself but I get it
if something breaks and
can  that's true i
understood how this is works
world champion so that will increase and
was high when you
try to hit your first ass et gi very very numbers
we haven't had it yet he has also
grown well at significantly faster than
four essays that  fastest 16
minutes knows a bit about sneakers who of
course also know this network around
75 times in the 10,000 of the
collection bought ferrari because I take art with me
additional topic of the community
that's also like to be right
call it then performance driven
only now how  a lot of people think that
with this club, like in vichy, there
is potential for the next round
if history is there  nter is the gasoline
I think is already an enormously strong
lost again well so the team
different verticals then
already as we can see very
a certificate or in that case
comment under our net the first
and there actually came again and again so
understand well  it's not so
bring it with you or set it up you have to
say three years
ok that's it so much so they say so all the gysi
now at immobilia also have
to minister a lot about brands most of the time i've
finally finished what I
thought before ok what you  your next the
collective whether that's on board apples or
and the people connected to
unfortunately was rejected by you
i also learned and are all right
accordingly he is now presented
the second thing i was so excited about
was an nfc from kazuki up to 1 degree  he
and said give me ten million
to all the data and facts
super early i think so in 2007 we came into existence
usersweearnmoneysowelcome
watch collectors and will
at least consider selling it and
jobs had 5000 euros at the time are sneakers
so after that it works well
I think that wasn’t so heated
there should be one so even
tyrannosaurus rex we say
if you ask them now over five
i found the future topic save so
fast with the topic we can grow
seminar well booked of
course but on the other hand
had an nfc or some kind of
the judging on the one hand
this goes to this thesis and it
is great that we want to go to
networks now and so he already has
certificates are there again
so the dbs from casino royale
was four months wears seo then the watches
euro i do  from that 20 and in which I
model is the cache erwin so they
said no are now back on the
a  Bought other topics in which you also
invest and from before it used to be more like
we take everything out of the process
I'm now clearly interested in
saying that's relatively quick because
if you assume that
top new enev projects and had
exciting thrillers I can say  know i'm up to
22,000 dollars is already quite a bit has
recognized that this
, so to speak, somehow thought of this myself so
after the long-term price development
have very good kastner kurdish cross
and then i'm with you goes for a
buy will be poland is of course
about the table  i just had a
generally in a banksy comes the
token and you have the stuff
to say but it's still
out for the user he can in principle
you can also blue chips are
you trying again in the next eight years
that it  there is no way
to keep art in the broadest sense for years is that is
able to achieve is that the german
i ka  ufe there now what what is a
token we want to optimize towards that there is
from james bond also that would be a
reason that you blue chip you have that as a
German right so it worked despite
already very strong numbers it
works at all and I have
66 million  years old was super super
behind are we still something
saab has a career as a civil servant then that could
buy collectivism like that we have
something to participate with which he's
already worked
with janka advice we'll clarify with
janka the shoes and  everything else we have that
year is great so another agency exactly
you of course not very professional
we can do it for cost reasons like you
also how we spend our money but the
topic of e-commerce in general the
reserved and let’s take a look now
I can understand
but in all  Kind of correct are
probably good that doesn't make
otherwise also a very best  other clocks are
worse than that means the blocks
but the court said they are already
relatively large returns are okay
how do you have the e-mail system at the end
at some point in the garage I
have the chance right now in June
24 hours would be cool two days namely
always  had more users and the users
you are you are a football change
and
giant leaps more but it's me
quite the dbs that's the aston
deep and long with the theme
new round race team because we on each
of what you okay okay
really really big  style over it's
all e-mail systems are of course that
as a ruse in the way they're
doing right now you now have a certified right to a
buyer in the market so
now hey that's not in any way planned for
it actually what else now you only
know  what we have with him me
and then i'll do it in three years
we can theoretically save if
that
's just certificates what can set
to milan
with it
I think that the the topic is so
much then one way or another I have a
watch good auction lately then
I can really recommend and then have explained
that will then
change people and I'm
not really excited because they're scared as
well  a little less than the hour it was the
subject of art there is probably only
football clubs as for example how
we take it a few more are
actively asked
about it so a small part of it is exactly right so it came out
a year and we
sell it i experienced i
can still  already doing analyzes in the median
meanwhile and still back in the
i everything mobile is of course
basically three people who
we also bought in a large one that was
so collectively relatively early
in principle if you look at it that’s
relatively possible in europe  to grow fast
i basically that there something like now
by the way also if you do the stuff now
okay okay yeah  very exciting so we
you if you make such a
personal rolex is four away so to speak
if now ok there are first people
we have now grown massively
again make big family offices to some extent
and also bought it that is also super
can’t use it  that's true have
something collective in it according to
martin den he drives in casino royale
think three weeks we have
exciting assets so art eat
a king belongs the better one
but basically it's a fraction
quicker than de cv kollaritsch
because i think they're very nice  but not yet
a team ask what was what and are
field and
team will have decided what to buy
believe that is still developing
you have a company and say about it and
today just somehow make friends
yes now how the first
push will become ultra important channel  we
now there's the usa yes there is the usa
clearly so what you already is that
exciting so sports graz is going he
said  t ok then let's consider if
collects alone and that's i
probably would because you don't if in the
would you this is up to now yes i
even mean with the one limited so
to communicate something like that you think it's
great older watches or older
fractionation found  so have the
different rolex has been we
also a few weeks ago some podcast
are super interested in it and
how much does it cost i think it is
enough money to buy the we are
now chasing the shopping
cart and since then it will double for just
that  we don't buy it and it
says the car is very good there is
money on the model we
really solve the aspect that it's a
full through the roof in america and to own it
need one you now have to bring all the rest
with you too  a banksy a
damien believe in the medium term for us that's a
lot over of course a lot in a moderate way in the
same way as we do it
that's it at expo on the subject of real
different from car do you drive
which one says go patek philippe that
said that we had porsche
with johann könig and how do we
say there are rally cars there are
there packed together where also for
our turnover  every quarter we have
vehicles or artists quite clearly
with a market that needs you
can then experience them all in
can because that's just the way it is if of
course the end point
at some point is the rolex or
the products themselves in the house  then comes
what we want to be we want
professionalism the markets for
example so now a good one in the rookie
then we dropped the next watch
theories e.g. also told me is a kind of
together a nice
Börgermann we now give people purposefully
the German was also a guest  ears
three from the film such a broken
15,000 euros 15,000 i have my own
estate and see it a few others
what we art that  you hirst at home
is the key word we have some
example exciting point of these
that understand relatively well whether it
suits me and where we say okay how does the
basic idea behind it, so to speak, that is a
collectible that means the
faction is aryanized that of course
we are a lot  material the last quarter you
map of ireland i believe that
there are a few blocks
alpha see the points for yourself on the
not at all
checker finished watches and always top
educates investor and then always had
early access that is when we
analyze spread to authorities whether  one
themes also what but definitely his
four rolex is we we made for
you can't use it
we see it so there are
no alternative expert can you
was so I've always had it since I
or I think the next one  will be
relic of the future because the
third investment class you can't
market 90 percent cash game can
out  grabbed because I'm so crazy
and so on and so forth and is doing
basic idea is the exchange for
pretty clever idea resorted to
so I would mean you who else I
forgot to explain so a topic which
also exciting artists
see that people are basically
two weeks  first watches notice
what two more on the market i also found
that they also lose kassel values
dly come back that was also about sayin
in the overall situation how many festi
als or at your roadshows we only found
something to have in these 60 us ho
e 6  millions made
20 was i thought she was just awesome she was of
course a bit one dimensional kind
only to invest in stocks or to be collective in crypto
if you bought that clearly
offered 90,000 euros where
collective liked saying that
okay because i have her in her first
season  also together make
trends but that's a smart thing what
happens to polimex
clear  more people for that
if that's the next thing you
understand so well there's
also something you're doing there the
bafin dressed a funny funny colleague
people don't actually notice if that's
the topic I think if the
disclaimer is banksy i got me
we already had other works of art back
then it's a lot
too expensive to communicate because there's only
going to be very
exciting ones
we wanted the whole thing accordingly yes with
contacts matter back then so that can
and do but now last quarter 3 will
democratize its asset
in the shopping cart but because everything
that you look at it again is
more subtle they have in principle say
directly  would see digital on daimlers
next thinks then you
buy from what he knows who fests  tellen so
i think it felt like six weeks and the topic is of
interest there can be
more expensive again for free exactly
pro7 we've been here ruhnke that
's actually the only thing you
certain people who can say who is there
we have as said example
we are  to be honest
cash more collective buying so
regulatory authority the african was
just order home what
class the super positive emotional made
millions so i have
to say that the
new wife and new category into the
market and then handbags super fast
on ownership to one
you say okay everything there what has our
one can I like that also acted and
asked and so also came that I also have to that
myself so when we go to
eat at home and only a certain of
course now today in the way of
our  customer is on average 33 years
of age and then have
a quad last quarter  ls q1 is
for users who actually have
point football or that are and where
can use without that is really
albert einstein we are so original
very zeitgeist and that has no
why am I there but if now
toxic assets and that means that
the search for the
talks on where can you get a
banksy clear that we call the people their own
contact topic and the goods are so
what you can invest in is
too structured then said okay we’ll try it
in the meantime you can do
that now so that  he quite relationships
investments.de mostly or best
freecom but what is a photo he found
there is also relatively general but you
reluctant so we buy there
old and as a percent male use it
founder who has also secretly going public in the last few years
loosing money is the topic of watches and he
described documents online
people you have here now and concerns the
from wi  r both parties asked we
probably also corresponding new
zeitgeist and then
we basically pass by
saying that a unique user so you
that you as a ruse or
so during an investor founded the
first pcs we basically talked about what pro active
dropped 33 of these
rolex happened what the topic knows back to
want to give your shares to
have no one
in the app store right home the interest
i say
really sell blue chips
now so that's similar to what you think with
a very  i
see what kind of nas you have or what
kind of possibilities you have to be careful that you don't do that is a world star painted the world but like
when we've decided what we're going to
get as i said that's where is
the european startup even a
quarter of growth and  in terms of sales
that's what always has first
but just got into the louis that
's i think that's the app from  the
once for the basic thesis that we say
then that is how much more exciting to
belong to the work of art by damien
addressed because of course he drives a
car and i think if you
actually do that to diversify it
makes a round on 100 million plus
many pictures  this type of there is
that you still searched with him
advantage hate 2 if you
had to do hard route in the medium term also
cooperation between nike have
now find it exciting on our
don't carry cars just the expensive
ones you where am i from we have we  above
me no one reports if we have a
people between 20 to 40 different
that you think is so i used to
have you that works relatively well he
has been hired that of course
has somehow belonged to 93 percent of shares
and city percent make a pre-approval for
translated in the direction of digital then it's
the 40 we'll also increase it in the factory  rd
it now 150 exactly the same
you promise that even a father who
says i want this correct to have
a huge effect on the
network of dealers and
sell and i can also now
have bought variety school year blue
hirst the shares 1 to 10 and the
with again  setbacks absolutely as i
continue to have the closed shop and get
a network in america and
and then you can then i
made a big mistake that we
price development of these watches the price
something will not
be perceived differently in the future because i always have
yes you have 50 people but we are
72% moved to 24 percent energy is to
carry as little as possible and that costs
you invest more than maybe your
own of
course not just because the at home
exposure with us fraction
alized auction houses have experts on it
is thought  did last summer
kinda i dont know the top
kinda go a gallery i
I don't know I'm not successful now 1 1 I've had
significantly less success than we and my
parents
did too, it's up to me, well, they're solved right away, but
every kilometer was bought comic books
i wouldn't have anything now where i where
digital not totally the goal that
is and are traded with us of
course first painted 750 times you
people give the exhibitions with us
are also certified that's what
i want 15 partners infinite like you
but if you today  get trip to of
course the takeaway effects which
now also
belong to the corresponding also the podcast and i don't think
there is a summer the first whiskey
not which ones where do you get for example
trading cards usa too and of course i thought to
grow very strongly so
but also on one  about victories and
that, well, exactly that means on
the one hand we will
only on our pl  attform but you
will also find them say it has for
you not to unpack
important ones and exactly okay okay
probably not see any interest and
so also relatively through
diversified to take the other thing
is so that's the question as
verticals there  let's help no mistakes to banksy
i would say it was that that
's a lot of money at the moment in
if then you need that the effect
so our our day on the subject there
is something like that happen status quo would you
also open
me the value here  these dbs from
significantly less than the founders the
marketing exactly relatively strong so
perspective there wanted to go yes exactly for that
crass what's going on here in germany
that's a very clear direction but so
always find it exciting that's how it is
we'll be back soon it's natural
now sharing means people is so it will
basically have there is an imprint of it
but that's that  i understand but
i had a very good one at the time and
make essays and then try with the offer
already
on the other side technologically
probably that now 415,000 will
be that good to have the dream or
the founded in 2018 we already have in 2018
the total desire even to
it's not like that when I of course I know
completely new possibilities of
course already have different advantages of
the film doing what you also
still feels nike to yes
but had to do the head up if you
so that the original and that
in london  actually the ones with the top
imagine it like this if now always
and where do the buyers come from
than really having that so that you can make that possible
with our app more people
we now have out of 90,000
in europe you now have almost
mine over  a panini pictures from before
so also a horny is a horny piece
beforethatstarts alittlelater
edition model from that we go ha  ben
unter den linden riesenhaus sold
make it of course also for crazy
with heftis and
vagni galeries which thinks very very closely then
but that would be, so to speak, the watch
one page in these topics to the
only one that sells with the topic so
quickly because of course we don't
almost  100 percent roughly there you have a
lot of people first of
all if you see quite a lot at some
point then see 2 formal offices and
to invest in collectibles from 50
also to diversify but
that I have collected when I have I
retrospectivelyandhowmanyinvestors
aretheonly oneswho growitin the
of history that is of course tackled
touch point complicated because i
i now understand where that
we are now giving some of
these goods here 75 we have always been with of
course our payment percentage is
euros per year and accordingly  can
two full albums from before if i
don't put that on so  with all these things
,alot ofpeople have the feeling
that we are a part
would offer emotion on ebay today or or
[music]
[music  ]
[  Music]
[music]
[laughter]
[music  ]
[music]